how do you get moral and political
progress if you don't get truth if you
have a situation where individuals can't
agree on first
[Music]
principles hello and welcome to the
Enlightenment and its
Alternatives the enlightenment advocated
reason science democracy and Universal
human rights as a grounding for human
morality and social organization
in the quarter Millennium since to what
extent have these ideals been realized
has the enlightenment in fact been
successful in bringing about moral
progress or are there viable
alternatives to the enlightenment Vision
joining us to discuss this fascinating
topic tonight are two speakers who
barely need introduction nevertheless I
will give you one all the same first of
all we have Steven Pinker Steven is the
Johnstone family professor of psychology
at Harvard University and one of the
most prominent public intellectuals of
our time Steven is the author of
rationality what it is why it seems
scares white matters and also
Enlightenment now the case for reason
science humanism and progress also
joining us is John mimer John is the r
Wendell Harrison distinguished service
professor of political science at the
University of Chicago and is considered
to be one of the most influential
international relations theorists of his
generation he is the author of how
States think the rationality of foreign
policy and the great delusion liberal
dreams and international realities each
speaker is going to have round about
five or so minutes to lay out their
pitch for us and the provocation that
I'll be asking both of them to respond
to is we associate Valu such as
universal liberty and justice with the
enlightenment do they harm or hinder the
world or do they help the world now
Stephen I'm going to turn to you first
Enlightenment values what do you think
thank you so what are Enlightenment
values or Enlightenment ideals in a
nutshell I would say it's the ideal that
we should use reason to improve human
flourishing uh what do I mean by reason
well open deliberation Science History
evaluation of ideas and the fruits of
Reason have been implemented in certain
uh institutions in particular liberal
democracy regulated markets and
international institutions that would be
the enlightenment ideal in a
nutshell what do I mean by flourishing
well I mean things that each of us wants
for ourselves and by extension can't
deny to others Life Health sustenance
Prosperity peace freedom safety
knowledge Leisure happiness now the enl
ideals enlightment are not to be
confused with the idea that we should
venerate some great men of the 18th
century they were just guys it's the
ideas to count uh and certainly not that
we should exalt the West because the
West has always been ambivalent in its
commitment to Enlightenment ideal there
are plenty of counter Enlightenment
themes that have had great influence in
the west uh what are the Alternatives
well of course there's religion that we
should obey God's Commandments and holy
scriptures there's romantic nationalism
and authoritarianism that Nations
embodied in strong leaders should strive
for historic greatness there's various
forms of zero some struggle that
subjugated victim groups must overcome
aggressive aggressive groups and their
reactionary ideologies that we should
reject modernity and return to a golden
age uh has the enlightenment worked well
we've had a quarter of a millennium to
find out we can compare this what has
happened in the last 250 years for the
various dimensions of human flourishing
so let's go to the data uh life
expectancy worldwide uh for Millennia
hovered around 30 years of age today it
is more than 70 years um worldwide and
uh more than 80 in developed countries
child mortality historically anywhere
from a third to a fifth of children died
before the age of five now it is uh 3/10
of 1% but 4%
worldwide uh famine was uh one of the
horsemen of the apocalypse and could
strike anywhere when there was a crop
failure today uh famines have been
decimated and occur only in war zones
and in some
autocracies extreme poverty uh 200 years
ago about 90% of the world lived in what
we would today call Extreme poverty
today it's less than 9%
uh great power War the uh 800 pound
gorillas of the day uh several hundred
years ago were pretty much always at War
today they are never at War the last
great power War pitted the us against
China in Korea 70 years ago um democracy
there used to be a handful of
democracies now a slight majority of
countries are democratic even with the
Democratic recession of the last decade
or so uh all the great States and
Empires used to uh meet out Justice by
gruesome forms of torture like
crucifixion breaking on the wheel
disembowelment but during the
Enlightenment there was a wave of
abolitions of judicial torture including
the United States prohibition of cruel
and unusual punishment uh slavery used
to be ubiquitous all the great uh States
and Empires practiced it starting in the
enlightenment there was a trickle of
abolitions that grew into a flood today
slavery is not legal anywhere on Earth
um hom side in Europe used to be about
35 per 100,000 per year in uh Europe now
it's about 1 per 100,000 per year other
parts of the world are more dangerous
but they've also seen declines used to
be that about 10% of the world was
literate a couple of hundred years ago
now it's closer to 90% especially if you
look at people under the age of of 25
and it used to be that about less than a
fifth of the world had a better uh basic
education today it's uh almost four
fifths uh also today countries that that
are Guided by Enlightenment ideals and I
would roughly uh identify those with
liberal democracies are according to um
uh our best data the healthiest
countries the safest in terms of of of
safety from from violent crime and War
the cleanest in terms of measures of
Environmental Quality the happiest and
they are the most popular destination of
people who vote uh with their feet
people want to go to Liberal democracies
if they possibly have the opportunity
well I'll I'll leave the Cas of the
Enlightenment at that for now and uh
look forward to hear what John what John
has to say I want to make it clear that
I'm not arguing that there has been no
progress since 1680 which is when the
enlightenment started uh and I'm not
arguing that the enlightenment didn't
contribute to some of that progress some
of which Steve described in his
presentation my argument has to do with
the question of whether or not uh the
enlightenment has led to moral and
political progress and when we talk
about moral and political progress we're
talking about first principles we're
talking about questions regarding the
good life and the question is has the
enlightenment created a
situation where there is large scale
consensus almost overwhelming consensus
on questions about first principles on
questions about the good life that would
be evidence in my opinion of moral
progress and I think that's uh an
argument that Steve makes uh in his work
that we have achieved uh both moral and
political progress as a result of the
Enlightenment and I of course disagree
with that and I want to make three
points first of
all the core or argument is that
unfettered reason leads individuals to
come to agreement about questions
regarding the good life in other words
unfettered reason or what Steve calls
the escalator of Reason leads us toward
truth it leads us towards agreement on
first principles and therefore we make
moral and political progress my argument
is that un FedEd reason involving lots
of individuals does not lead to
agreement in fact it leads to
significant disagreement people cannot
agree about first principles they cannot
agree about questions regarding the
political Goods uh they cannot agree
about questions regarding Justice and
therefore you're not making moral and
political progress and in fact this is
why politics is so important if you look
at Steve's work politics is not very
important because he believes that in
the end you're getting large scale
agreement on these Central questions my
argument is you don't get central
agreement you get disagreement and
sometimes that disagreement is so
fervent that people end up killing each
other and this is why politics is so
important in my story my second point is
that people who focus on the
enlightenment focus on the individualism
uh radical individualism is a so
associated with the enlightenment my
view is that human beings are social
animals to begin with who carve out room
for their
individualism but because they're social
animals to begin with human beings
belong to tribes today we call them
Nations human beings are very tribal and
when you're in a tribe or you're in a
nation your identity is inextricably
bound up with that Nation you have
interests you have ways of looking at
the world you have views about what is
just and what is not just that are bound
up with being a member of that Nation so
in the end what that means is that sense
that individuals are parts of Nations
and Nations disagree on first principles
makes it even harder to reach agreement
on what are uh moral and political uh
answers to the big questions in life
then finally there's the matter of
international relations uh I actually
believe that people who focus on the
enlightenment argue uh Allah Emmanuel
Kant that by using reason we can come up
with what Kant called Perpetual peace uh
I don't believe that at all I believe
that because the International System is
anarchic which is to say that there's no
higher authority in that system uh that
if a state us uses reason to think about
how to survive in that system and of
course survival has to be its principal
goal that state and other states are
going to engage in security competition
and that security competition is
sometimes going to lead to war so in an
anarchic system like the International
System basically you have a situation
where reason leads not to peace but it
leads to competition and sometimes
deadly conflict so it's for those three
reasons that I disagree with the
argument that the
enlightenment leads to consensus to some
sort of truth about political and moral
factors thank you so Steve if if I could
return to you and just picking up on
John's on John's arguments here is there
is is politics slightly missing from um
from the account you've given us so far
I mean I mean it looked incredibly uh
Rosy and very optimistic even but is
there sort of some political context
that have been missing for example are
liberal democracies attractive because
actually historically speaking they were
colonial powers and the countries that
are not so attractive were put into very
difficult economic situations by
successful and quite aggressive states
which are now liberal democracies is
there any scope for agreed Frameworks
for reasoning and shared decision-
making that could lead to the kind of
accumulated colle progress that
Enlightenment seems to feel is necessary
oh absolutely it's called democracy uh
the Enlightenment thinkers were obsessed
with how you can have a political um uh
organization that is is not vested in
say a absolute monarch with divinely
granted Powers uh and the um ideals such
as uh free speech and um uh democracy
were absolutely predicated on the fact
that people do disag agree there is
absolutely no uh presumption that
everyone has the the same values or the
same beliefs that's why you need
democracy that is given that people
aren't going to agree how are we going
to uh govern ourselves um on the other
hand it's important not to uh exaggerate
how much disagreement there is compared
to say uh 250 or 500 years ago compared
to say the era of the wars of religion
uh the world's Nations did sign the
universal Declaration of Human Rights
and it has informed um dozens uh per
scores of of constitutions so um the
universal Declaration of Human Rights is
pretty detailed and you've got the every
country signing on to it often you know
sometimes in the breach sometimes
hypocritically but the a lot of the
ideals actually command pretty wide
Ascent but not a universal Ascent there
are still of course religious Fanatics
there are still authoritarian despots
there are still uh Glory mad uh
expansion leaders but the uh the ideals
of the Enlightenment are not a guarantee
that everyone will come around but they
are arguments about which way we ought
to be heading um in terms of
individualism another point that that
John mentioned uh you know among the
individual um uh needs uh benefits is
belonging to a group belonging to a
family having friends belonging to
institutions belonging to organizations
there's nothing about recognizing the
right of individuals that is uh
that it contradicts the idea that we
like to belong to groups as long as they
don't coerce us as long as we can leave
those groups and that includes Nations I
mean it is true that that people belong
to Nations but not everyone in a nation
agrees with everyone else in the nation
that's why we have arguments and
political parties and contested
elections and people who come and go and
leave and disagree with their leaders
unless they're threatened with with jail
for doing so it is exactly a precept of
the Enlightenment in its commitment to
democracy that people within a nation
actually disagree with each other and
that the fact that the nation might have
a uh a religion an ideology doesn't mean
that it is right for every last
individual to be coerced into uh
conforming to it and we know
historically and from current events
people don't there's there's lots of
dissent in every country as long as it's
allowed um in terms of the uh whether
the uh competition for security means
that we will um perpetually be at War
War I mean that predicts that war the
rate of War should be at pretty much a
constant level throughout history and
it's not it's gone you know it's gone
way down especially since the end of the
second World War and the rates go up and
down I think depending in good part on
nation's commitments to um Enlightenment
ideals versus uh thirst for Glory and
Grandeur and preeminence U that's a
variable that we see goes up and down
and varies from country to Country
countries that used to be at each
other's throats for centuries or
millennia have decided that they'd be
better off cooperating so that can
happen too I don't think that the um
nature of the International System pins
us to a constant level of War at every
period in history Steve I think if you
read your book carefully um and you read
better Angels your other important book
from my point of view uh carefully it's
very clear that you talk about truth and
allowing truth to Prevail that's
language uh from your book right well
approaching the truth yes uh we don't
know what it is but we try to get there
okay but I would just say that how do
you get moral and political progress if
you don't get truth if you have a
situation where individuals can't agree
on first principles and they battle it
out I mean look at the United States
today the red versus blue divide and we
could point to all sorts of other
examples like this how do you make
progress right it just seems to me that
progress is inextricably bound up with
the concept of Truth now when you talk
about it you point to progress as the
coming of liberalism and in fact you say
that there is this escalator of Reason
out there and you say explicitly that
we're getting smarter and you say
explicitly that getting smarter means
you become liberal right so it looks
like in your story to me that the truth
is becoming a liberal establishing a
liberal society and I think that's a
hard argument to make I like Li
liberalism very much I'm thrilled I'm
ecstatic about the fact that I was born
into liberal America right so I'm not
against liberalism but as you well know
there are a lot of people on the planet
who don't like liberalism at all there
are many opponents of liberalism and if
you look at what's been happening on the
planet with regard to liberalism liberal
democracies have been decreasing since
2006 so it doesn't look like such a Rosy
picture but my more important point is
do you really want to identify progress
with liberalism and argue that anybody
who opposes liberalism is uh therefore
uh in the wrong yeah so I would identify
progress really with with human
flourishing now some of those ideals
like Freedom do overlap with liberalism
and i' be been prepared to argue that uh
that they better values but some of them
like living longer uh kids not dying
mothers not dying in childbirth uh
people not getting uh stabbed to death
in muggings people not getting thrown in
jail because they disagree with the king
um I think those are I get some of those
are liberal values equality of women you
know there are a lot of people who don't
agree with the ideal of equality of
women to to put it mildly but um but I
would argue that those so there are some
that that I think are universally agreed
upon such as health longevity um
sustenance there's some that are uh
where there are holdouts but there is
still a a pretty uh significant Trend
such as equality of women um the
countries that deny women the vote have
been dwindling so the only one left is
is the Vatican um the Direction in terms
of laws that uh discriminate against
women is that they are falling off the
books the uh countries that have laws
that criminalize homosexuality are
liberalizing that so actually I think
there is actually a a trend towards
liberal values but um and and I think
they are most defensible that is if you
have uh an open discussion an open
argument if if people uh from different
backgrounds have to come together and
decide what they agree upon which
they're motivated to do in order to have
a uh a global Community where they're
not at each other's throats then they do
tend to settle on certain Universal
values and the universal Declaration of
Human Rights is the the most obvious
example if someone were to say that the
first uh Universal principle is we
accept Jesus Christ as our savior well
you know a lot of people are going to
fall off the fall fall by the wayside
but if it's that people should uh have
an education that people shouldn't be
jailed because of their opinions then
it's you much harder for someone to
argue against them and and historically
that's why I think liberal values in
general have uh actually have uh
increased you're right that democracy
has uh stalled in the last 15 years or
so but still as the graph that I uh
threw up before showed it has stalled it
may even have gone down a bit but it's
still way higher than it was you know 20
years ago to say nothing of 50 years ago
100 years ago 200 years ago but there's
not a consensus there that's the point
but I just want to go a step further on
this one of the points that's clear from
reading your book is that you believe
that if you go to the academy Academia
the world that you and I operate in
there are huge numbers of people who you
think are uh at odds with your way of
looking at the world these are people
who are not using reason for good
ends if the academy where you would
expect people to privilege reason is
filled with individuals who think in
ways that you think are contrary to
producing progress how can you argue
that we're moving in a positive
direction and it's not only that the
academy that you point to you also point
to a large number of great thinkers
people who uh uh enjoy great esteem in
the academy people like Fuko people like
fan people like nature as people who are
hindering progress people who are
getting in the way you also argue that
anybody who believes in these isms these
ideologies you know is asking for
trouble it's also ideologies are also a
hindrance to progress on the moral and
political front given this panoply of
forces that are acting in ways that are
contrary to your argument how can you
argue we're making progress yes so and
you know I'd be the first to say that
there are a lot of pathologies in a
number of our institutions not least the
one that employs the the two of us uh
and you know in that regard your
institution is doing a whole lot better
than mine uh University of Chicago comes
close to the top in rankings for freedom
of expression and Harvard comes close to
the bottom I'm I'm working to try to
change that but uh yeah so I mean the
most General answer to your question is
a belief that there has been progress is
not a belief that everything gets better
everywhere for everyone all the time uh
that wouldn't be progress that would be
a miracle and I you know I don't believe
in miracles progress is uh is
incremental it is it has setbacks it has
to because it's not a force of the
universe it's not a and you're you're
right that there was a conception of
progress as some Mystical Force that
carries us ever upward that's not what
I'm advocating at all quite the contrary
most of the forces of uh the uh of of
the universe are kind of trying to grind
us down and we push back with
deliberation with reason with argument
with evidence and there's no guarantee
of success sometimes Brute Force wins
sometimes people are under the spell of
delusions or malignant ideologies um so
there's no the idea that the the
normative argument of what we ought to
do and the U descriptive argument of
where we are are are separate it could
be that there are certain things we
ought to do and not enough people are
doing them and they should should change
and we should try to persuade them to
change uh but yeah things could go wrong
and and in some places things have gone
wrong I think on average we're better
off now than we were a 100 years ago or
200 years ago to say nothing of 2,000
years ago but uh but yeah stuff happens
things go wrong progress is not always
the getting it right and accumulating
that rightness maybe it's the
understanding more about how you might
go about getting it right John is that
is that a convincing argument for you no
but my point so is that for an academic
like you an academic like Steve and an
academic like me we should realize that
the Liberation and reason in different
individuals leads to different
conclusions about what is the political
or moral good at all of our universities
what you find are huge numbers of people
who are very smart who have truly
impressive uh critical faculties who
can't agree on much of anything
yeah I mean I think that that's a bit of
an exaggeration there there certainly
plenty of disagreement there's no
question but how many and again by the
way I don't want I want to distinguish
Academia which is an institution which
you know as we both agree have has some
pathologies but that's not the same as
the larger say Republic of letters the
intellectual sphere which also includes
you know think tanks and Publications
and newspapers and independent bloggers
and so on um but even within Academia
there's not a whole lot of people who
would give a defense of of a return to
tradition gender rules that women should
be kept out of the workplace or that gay
PE that homosexuality should be
criminalized uh or that uh war is heroic
and manly and thrilling and spiritual
and that Humanity will uh become
decrepit if we ever uh have peace
arguments that people used to have that
are pretty much uh obsolete that we
should have racial segregation um that
we should look to the Bible as a source
of history as opposed to science uh
there's plenty that we agree on on and
there is there certainly a pretty big
froth of disagreement on top but uh but
there is intellectual progress in the
sense that there are crazy superstitions
that were pretty and and monstrous
beliefs that people by by and large have
abandoned at least in in arenas where
you can uh make arguments about them so
John are you confident that things
aren't going to slip backwards again or
do you see new myths forming to replace
the old ones well it's not so much myths
again I think that reason can lead
individuals to come up with smart
views that the world Works in one way
and lead other individuals to come up
with smart views that the world Works in
other ways in international relations
the world I operate in I have a
particular theory of realism I argue
that realism best explains how the world
Works Steve is a very smart guy and he
uses his critical faculties to think
about how the world works and he comes
up with a fundamentally different view
of international politics than I do it's
what I would call a liberal View and
that is my basic point that smart
individuals right can use their critical
faculties to come up with different
views and when you have different views
how do you have progress the fact that
Steve and I disagree about intern
progress about international relations
makes me wonder whether it makes sense
to talk about us achieving progress in
understanding how the world
works if we take say the history of
science as our guide to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit I a.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest
ideas